hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
the Consumer Electronics Show is
officially over and there's a lot of
cool stuff so this is the coolest stuff
I saw at CES 2015 now every year it
feels like about three quarters of the
show is a TV showcase of course this
year there were TVs everywhere curved
TVs flat TVs ultra wide TVs OLED TVs
quantum TVs not a lot of 3d TVs which
was good I'm kind of glad 3d is dead but
most of all everyone had a 4k TV of some
kind which made the pixel lover inside
of me very happy but believe it or not
we also saw multiple 8k TVs which looked
absolutely insane obviously there's not
a whole lot of 8k video out there so
these mostly played these constructed
demos and time lapses which looked
awesome but they even looked a lot
better than the current 4k TVs to me
which was actually saying something my
favorite TV though had to be Sony's
super thin 4k Android TV it came in at
something like 5 millimeters thin which
is thicker than probably the phone
you're holding right now and it was
literally so thin that you could grab
the corner with two fingers and twist it
and it'll actually Bend a little bit so
obviously not something you want to do
with your TV but to me that was the most
impressive form factor and it would look
pretty badass mounted up on a wall I
gotta say though of all the new display
technology that's out there I think my
next TV upgrade is gonna have to be led
I'm on the lookout this year for a great
4k OLED TV and if you want to see
actually my explanation of that you can
check out my recent quantum dot explain
video I'll leave a link right below that
like button now speaking of 4k TVs we've
seen always a whole bunch of ways to
watch 4k at CES all these 4k TVs but
more than ever now this year we're
seeing more ways to shoot 4k so last
year there were one or two major
announcements but this year there were
several new 4k cameras a couple 4k
handycams over at the Sony booth all for
a lower price in last year and also some
of their existing cameras could have 4k
shooting unlocked with an external
recorder so that combined with some 4k
action cameras in the new 4k GoPro and
you can tell that shooting 4k no longer
has to be an ordeal with a huge camera
anyone can do it and this is going to be
the year of 4k now see
has been an increasingly less important
show for mobile but the one smartphone
that stood out this year was the LG G
flex 2 for sure it's a much improved
version of the original G flex we saw
last year in a lot of ways it now has a
form factor that reminds me most of the
LG g3 so those back buttons are there it
has the same camera the laser autofocus
and it reminds me a lot in its shape of
the Galaxy Nexus the biggest improvement
here with this phone is the new display
so last year was this huge 720p Super
curved display this year it's a slightly
smaller 5.5 inch 1080p slightly less
curved a LED display and it looks much
better
and yes it's still flexible it also has
a self-healing back and apparently it's
supposed to be even better than the
original so you know I'm gonna try to
test that out on video as soon as I can
get my hands on it another cool thing I
saw was the Tesla Model X in the
Panasonic booth so I've talked a lot
about Tesla's since I showed the Model S
in this booth last year and the Model X
is one of the most popular things at the
whole show like it was constantly
swarmed even until the last day but I
managed to spend some quality time with
this electric prototype crossover and
noticed some cool things number one the
doors there are pretty obviously
different from any other car they're not
butterfly doors they're not going doors
they're not scissor doors they're not
suicide doors they're called Falcon wing
doors and they have their own unique
folding methods so you don't have to nip
the car next to you but you also don't
need all that much vertical space to
open and close them obviously this is
still a prototype and they open and
close kind of slowly and very
deliberately but I guess what's cool is
that they open and close by just a
button so the retracted door handles on
the back doors just stay retracted
number two the seats the Model X
obviously now has three rows of seats
the first row looking pretty standard
with some nice white leather seats
stitching headrests all that looks fine
second row of seats looks pretty cool
obviously all still power adjustable and
it switches to this black leather with a
red stitching and it looks like your leg
room will be a little bit tight if
you're in the middle seat but really the
third row is what you want to take an
eye on and really it's accessible by the
Falcon wing doors still and it's
supposed to have a decent amount of
legroom but I feel like if you're gonna
have people in all three rows someone is
going to be uncomfortable
either way number three is that
everything in this car looked a little
bit more refined than the interior of
the Model S obviously that was one of
the biggest complaints about the Model S
is that the interior didn't look like
something you'd find in a similarly
priced Mercedes or BMW or something so
it's kind of hard to do that without any
buttons or dials or knobs but the
touchscreen had a nicer bezel all the
trim looked a little bit better it just
looked like a much cleaner much more
luxurious interior even if it's not all
that complicated the steering wheel is
also new it has this two-tone look and
actually now has touch screens on either
side of the steering wheel for media
controls replacing even more of the
stuff that was previously knob so I'm
guessing these will either be
programmable or changeable after the
fact I also noticed this version also
has sideview mirrors which is only
notable because the last version of the
Model X I saw had cameras there instead
so yeah this is the all-electric
crossover that is expected to enter
production soon from Tesla but if you're
more into some gasoline-powered driving
machines you should definitely take a
look at the video I did on all the tech
in BMWs cars at their booth outside of
the North Hall which was pretty badass
some self-driving cars the i8 is a
hybrid some crazy-looking stuff they're
also sharp I think sharp had one of the
best booths at all of CES honestly not
only did they have a bunch of their TVs
but they had a ton of these bezel-less
displays using the same technology that
the sharp aquos crystal smartphone had
and a bunch of these formless displays
that you could make really whatever
shape you want which is crazy and we
also saw in that booth a see-through
display which I must say I definitely
stared at for a couple of minutes
because it was kind of actually blowing
my mind very cool I also want to mention
one more thing there was a bunch of
virtual reality stuff all over CES
scattered about the floor this year and
while I was getting footage of it I
realized you are guaranteed to look at
least a little bit ridiculous while
using it in fact the better the demo is
the more ridiculous you look
either way CES was a lot of fun I got to
hang out with a bunch of awesome
youtubers that were also all making dope
videos I'll leave some links below so
you can check those guys out and the
videos they made and even though there
were some things I didn't get to see
from companies like Dell and Asus I had
an awesome time and I'll definitely be
checking out a lot of those things in
separate upcoming videos this year so
definitely stay tuned for those
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]